[Musik]
ich bin rekord ist mir eine freude mit
mister schwarz ist das so
nein das ist meins stand der begriff
wird die regisseure hängen traditionell
ganz eng zusammen mit denen mit den
preisträger des besten films was mir
auffällt es beim leader natürlich keine
nominierung für eine frau bei den bei
der besten regie und das werde ich jetzt
wirklich langsam inzwischen muss ich
wirklich lachen jedes mal wenn diese
nominierung rauskommt denke ich ich bin
er schaue und ich bin es deswegen so
lachhaft weil ich den eindruck habe dass
das regiefach nummer eins ist dass die
männer einfach nicht gehen wollen und
ich bin ja das inzwischen so lächerlich
es gibt so viele frauen die regie führen
ja und die tolle für machen die große
filme machen kleine filme machen bunte
oder schwarz weiß oder wo auch immer
und sie gewinnen wenn ich sie gewinnen
kann ich da hätte eben porträt einer
jungen frau in flammen gewinnen müssen
meines erachtens er stattdessen kriegs
bank und die credit recht noch nicht mal
nominierung einen oscar ich glaube durch
da würden dem widersprechen aber ich bin
kein dichter
ich bin nur eine frau habe keine ahnung
warum 1917 so hoch gehandelt wird
nachdem ich ihn gesehen habe würde ich
sagen das ist krieg skitch und das kann
man sich technisch gut ansehen aber das
ist eine ärgerliche geschichte und das
alles hat man schon fünf bis sechs mal
deutlich besser gemacht und ich finde
dass das technische sich so vor als
andere schiebt in diesen film und diese
durchgehende kamerafahrt hat inhaltlich
überhaupt keinen sinn weil es kein
echtzeit film ist und entdeckt viel mehr
zeit als wirklich abgefilmt wird also
gibt es außer dass dieser registrierungs
beweisen will dass er das kann irgendein
grund
ich denke nein also lieber nicht
ich nehme an das ist hier eine
entscheidung geben könnte die mich schon
venedig überrascht hat denn da hat der
joker geworden von todd phillips hat
philips ja den natürlich sofort aus ich
vermute es könnte ihnen kriegen aber
dann hat es also das hat mich eigentlich
auch nichts zu tun der joker ist einfach
ein film der sehr viel zusammenfasst was
in amerika gerade passiert der es wagt
eine figur sich zum fokus zu nehmen
die eigentlich überhaupt nichts gutes
hat die die schlechten seiten sozusagen
vereint und die auch noch mehr oder
weniger zum held der geschichte zu
machen obwohl das sehr sehr gebrochen
erzählt wird und sie irgendwelche
negativen gedanken ich habe
ausschließlich negative gedanken
ich muss ja sagen wenn es denn
tatsächlich mit rechten dingen zuginge
wenn es wirklich darum ging was machen
die denn eigentlich und wirklich die
regisseure dann gibt es unter diesen
film überhaupt nur einen gegen oscar
gewinnen kann und das ist martin
scorsese francis züge sind so sparen wir
diese geschichte und die einzelnen
stränge die der geschichte in der hand
hält das ist wirklich großartig
dieser stein ist was besonderes er
bringt der familie wohlstand und gute
prüfungsergebnisse das ist ja wirklich
mit der von yahoo
für parasite bei der film ein unfassbar
umhaut weil er witzig ist weil er
traurig ist weil er dramatisch ist weil
er wirklich ein in den sessel drückt und
wieder rausholt innerhalb von 30
sekunden ist ein toller film versagt und
das wäre ungewöhnlich dass ein nicht
amerikaner dieses kalibers konnte mich
so machen ich hoffe und fast mal gut
gespielt und gut geschrieben und fassbar
gutes drehbuch und regie also definitiv
der für das drehbuch würde ich ihn
sofort ausgegeben also bei der regie hat
er eigentlich nie mehr
viele sind zugefügt werden weiß corsi
man doch wirklich den eindruck hat dass
er einfach auch aus seinem immensen
erfahrungsschatz kann die ganzen bilder
in einer andern firmen und die fließen
quasi von den rändern auch in diesem
film mit rein also ich finde er sollte
es werden
trotzdem da ich leider gottes vermute
dass hollywood langweilig ist und nicht
quentin tarantino nehmen wird denn das
wäre jetzt mal mit einem film wirklich
eine chance dem seinen ersten
regie-oscar zu geben denn once upon a
time in hollywood ist ein guter film
sam mendes ist der mann der es gewinnen
wird für 1917 ich werde extrem
unglücklich sein aber ich bin weit weg
wenn die oscars vergeben werden
über mich haben die leute haufenweise
diese dinge gesagt der kann ist
wahnsinnig sieht das nur diesen psycho
an der wand auch alle umbringen
jetzt kann natürlich der absolute
krönung muss man ja auch immer alles
durch gesessen haben es ist dann endlich
so weit ist der beste film das ist die
kategorie mit den aller meisten
nominierungen auch das leider gottes
eine unschöne entwicklung der letzten
jahre aber dass man jetzt bis zu zehn
filmen so was findet diesmal sind ein
bisschen weniger ich glaube wir sind bei
acht oder neun diesmal
langweilig schwer verdaulich
großartig
völlig wider
tarantino hat
märz
ausgesprochen komisch chancenlos
ab ins kino alles klar
was mich ärgern würde wäre das hier was
mich ärgern würde wären dass hier was
mich ärgern würde wäre das hier
dieses hier das finde ich natürlich toll
von kritik aber wie gesagt wenn ich
jetzt auch erstaunlich und irgendwo
würde es auch klatschen ich finde ich
weiß im gegensatz zu allen anderen
firmen die als bester film nominiert
sind sind bei allen die regisseure
produzenten mit ausnahme von thüringen
da ist nämlich die didaktik nicht
produzentin und insofern würde sie auch
mehr ausgehen es wäre zwar ihr film aber
ihre produzenten würde den ausgaben wenn
ja auch in ordnung aber irgendwie ist es
doch auch ein bisschen komisch
nein nein nein nein das funktioniert
nicht wenn man jetzt wirklich mal sagen
würde was bringt die filmkunst in diesem
jahr am weitesten nach vorne dann ist
der ganz klare gewinner unter diesen
filmen der die viel besseren sind gar
nicht nominiert perry site von dem
koreanischen regisseurs bong parasite
nimmt klassenkämpfer auseinandernimmt
gesellschaftsproblem auseinander die wir
gerade haben macht sehr tollen gefälle
auf von reicher und armer schicht von
leuten die irgendwie probieren
aufzusteigen und alles dafür tun und
leute die alles dafür tun um ihren
reichtum zu behalten
guten tag und das ganze aber mit witz
und fahrt um dramatik und brutalität zum
teil auch die einfach mit vorkommen muss
das ist unfassbar gut
jessica 1 erkennt elena chicago wiederum
wird aber der rest internationale firmen
werden und insofern ist alles wieder
offen
gerne können sie kommen dir das zweite
gestern morgen hat er uns darüber
informiert dass er den deutschen nach
setzen wird er denkt dass er sie vor
sich hertreibt dass ich nach
durchbrechen ihrer linie das blatt
wendet er täuscht sich derjenige der
stan gewinnen wird ist eben doch der
kriegsfilm 1917 und da wird man sich von
der technischen brillanz blenden lassen
und alles andere leider gottes
beiseiteschieben und warum ich denke
dass es gewinnt ist das denn mendes ganz
ans ende dieses films geschrieben hat
dass das eine erinnerung an seinen
eigenen vorfahren ist der dort in diesem
krieg wird gekämpft hat und der das
ganze überlebt hat und das ist sehr sehr
viel pathos hinten dran und hollywood
steht auch pathos ich könnte mir also
gut vorstellen dass das hier tatsächlich
einen filmpreis bekommt ich finde jetzt
hier nicht mal die karte dafür dass es
sehr vernünftig dass es nicht dabei ist
denn wie gesagt verdient hat jetzt nicht
aber gewinnen wird es trotzdem
wer gewinnt wer glaube ich ich glaube es
ist auch wirklich nicht dabei ich kann
das sein
naja da in der tat war dann irgendwie
hängen sehr stark an gott den
schrecklichen rennfahrer fühlen
naja
so was ist wunderbar